bienvenidos veamos el problema número 87
la máquina
produce el doble de partes de lo que
produce la máquina de la máquina de
produce 100 partes en 40 minutos si cada
una produce las partes a una tasa
uniforme cuántas partes produce la
máquina en 6 minutos
anotemos los datos que nos dan nos dicen
que la máquina be produce 100 partes que
es de partes
cada 40 minutos 40 minutos esto es igual
al 100 entre 40 es igual a 2.5 partes
por minuto
y aparte nos dicen que la máquina
produce el doble de partes que ve
entonces es igual a el doble o 2 por ver
v es 2.5 el doble de 2.5 es igual a 5
partes por minuto y nos preguntan
cuántas partes produce la máquina en 6
minutos así que a esta tasa de la
máquina da cinco partes por minuto la
tengo que multiplicar por los seis
minutos que me preguntan
estas unidades se van seis por cinco
treinta me queda que produce treinta
partes
cada seis minutos esta es mi opción a
este problema estuvo bastante sencillo
veamos el siguiente problema número 88
un collar se hace con hilo en cuentas
individuales que se colocan en cierto
patrón cuenta roja la voy a notar aquí
en cuenta roja cuenta verde cuenta
blanca cuenta negra y cuenta amarilla
que se repiten continuamente el collar
comienza con una cuenta roja y va a
terminar con una cuenta blanca entonces
n o el número de cuentas podría ser
igual a vamos a pensar en ello si n es
exactamente un múltiplo de 5 ya que
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 cuentas de colores
diferentes
fueron 5 entonces siempre terminaría con
la cuenta de color amarillo
y n fuera igual a 5 por cada 2 a un
múltiplo de 5 siempre terminaría con la
cuenta amarilla pero nos dicen que no
termina con la cuenta amarilla
veamos si n
fueron múltiplo de 5 + 1
terminaría con la cuenta roja que es la
siguiente en el patrón
pero no nos dicen que termina con la
roja entonces veamos si n fuera igual a
un múltiplo de 5 + 2 terminaría con la
cuenta verde que es esta que sigue pero
nos dicen que termina con la cuenta
blanca así que creo que ustedes ya se
dieron cuenta de cómo va esto n es igual
a un múltiplo de 5 + 3 y entonces aquí
va a terminar con la cuenta blanca así
que esta es nuestra fórmula y cualquier
múltiplo de 5 al que se le agregue 3 va
a terminar en 8 o en 3 pues los
múltiplos de 5 terminan en 5 o en 0 y al
sumarle este después 5 más 3 va a ser 8
hicieron más te después va a ser 3 y
veamos las opciones que nos dan
nos dicen bueno aquí está la primera
opción es 16 que no es porque no termina
ni en cero ni de noche
la siguiente opción es 32 que tampoco es
porque tampoco terminan en 0 ni en 8 la
siguiente opción 41 tampoco es la
siguiente opción es 51 que tampoco
cumple con esto y la última opción es 68
está pues si termina con 8 65 32 68 y es
nuestra opción
el siguiente problema
número 89 en un sistema de coordenadas x
y además tres demás que son los puntos
en una línea definida por la ecuación x
entonces can a que se da igual aquí lo
más fácil de hacer es definir ya en
términos de x si me dicen que x es igual
a este color casi no se nota voy a
cambiarlo si me dicen que x es igual
a 37
pues voy a dejar en términos de sumo 7
en ambos lados y lo divido entre 3 me va
a quedar que es igual a un tercio de x
+ 7 entre 37 entre 3
vemos que podemos hacer la pendiente de
esta línea es un tercio esto indica que
tan rápido sube la línea si me dan dos
puntos como encuentro la pendiente bueno
la pendiente es el cambio en entre el
cambio en x de los puntos voy a llamar
de uno a uno y de dos al otro entonces
de estos puntos voy a restar o ver la
diferencia entre y demás acá
de mascar que es está allí - está de acá
- ve - la idea entre
esta x + 3 a más 3 - esta x acá que es
a que se reduce esto se dan a menos se
van y me queda que es igual acá entre 3
es la pendiente pero también ya sabía
que la pendiente vale un tercio entonces
acá entre 3 es igual a un tercio
por lo que acá va a ser igual a 1
y esta es mi opción de
siguiente problema
número 90 a una tasa de m / s metros por
segundo
cuántos metros recorre un ciclista en x
minutos nos dicen que es la tasa m / s
minutos por segundo y nos preguntan
cuántos metros recorre en equis minutos
aquí hay que tener cuidado porque son
metros por segundo y lo que nos
preguntan está dado en minutos así que
pongamos todo en segundos así que vamos
a poner x en segundos sabemos que x
minutos va a ser igual a 60 por equis
segundos
y sabemos que la distancia es igual a la
rapidez por el tiempo
en este caso la rapidez son m / s m / s
por el tiempo que es este el segundo 60
por equis vamos a poner las unidades las
va a poner en otro color para que no se
confunda m / s metros
por segundo y aquí son 60 por equis
segundos estos segundos se van y me van
a quedar metros esto me va a quedar que
es igual igual a 60 por m por x
/ efe metros de hecho esta unidad mejor
la pongo en otro color para que sepamos
que esto azulito son las unidades
porque como usan las mismas letras como
las abreviaturas de las unidades pues
puede confundirse
y esta es mi opción
ok siguiente problema
número 91
si luciano tuviera el doble de edad de
lo que tiene sería 40 años mayor que
benito si benito es 10 años más joven
que el océano qué edad tiene luciano
bueno aquí nos dicen que si luciano
tuvieras el doble de su edad sería 40
años más grande que benito
y también nos dicen que luciano es 10
años mayor que benito 10 años mayor que
benito
y quieren conocer la edad de luciano
bueno lo que vamos a hacer es restar
estas dos ecuaciones
2 cl - l me queda el igual a 40 10 30pm
v pues quiere hacer él es igual a 30
luciano tiene 30 años de edad
que es nuestra opción de
muy bien con esto terminamos los vídeos
de esta sesión y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo